you know what is the worst [ __ ]
dessert
go on
the macaroons oh yeah no which kind of
all of them they never ever ever taste
as good as they love the sugary things
right the little chicken
oh yeah i actually an injury
they're obsessed with them yeah they're
[ __ ] happy because they're kawaii af
dude it was a thing in la or sf too
sometimes especially with dessert in
japan if it isn't instagram it's not
like instagramable it's not a dessert
macaroons for me are like that i eat two
and i'm like done for the year
it just tastes like [ __ ] you know what i
don't get
boba
that's that's that's like
i like boba
what just why why why is it so that's
also like a twice a year thing for me
it's like like boba is just the pumpkin
spice latte of asia
i [ __ ] said it okay i [ __ ] said it
it is it's good it's good it's just
melty yeah it's just milk tea
sometimes you just want milk tea and
there's nothing like
you
why'd you like why the [ __ ] do you like
boba dude do you know what tapioca is
like it's [ __ ] jelly i know
i don't like jelly i don't get i don't
get that it's just jelly you get the
tapioca it's just jelly you you're
putting one makes boba bob
you're putting you're getting milk tea
you're putting jelly in it yeah i don't
like tapioca i don't have it but then
you don't like boba then you're like
drinking milk that's literally you
literally just milked it i participated
i turned up to the the the chain
because you bought milky from a boba
place it doesn't automatically make it
but also the second reason why i love
boba is because of the hilarious [ __ ]
videos we get out of the absolute
carnage it causes from people choking on
the [ __ ] tapioca to people
[ __ ] up stabbing it it's an endless
supply of hilarious videos it's like
nothing to do with this bro
nothing to do with the photos it is very
funny but it's got nothing to do with
you dreaming but the part the reason one
of the reasons i love it is because the
endless entertainment value and that
when i love taking someone who's never
had boba to a boba place because they
always [ __ ] who hasn't had
who hasn't had boba in this day and age
what where in wales no one's had [ __ ]
time okay well okay yeah well of course
yeah
watching watching people drink tapioca
the first time and then just because you
can never ex you if you haven't drank it
it goes up the straw really yeah they
struck it too hard and just stabbed
because yeah because you've never drank
anything that is like that no one's
drinking balls that big so
i can't come back
personally
yeah so whenever you drink it right it
always catches you off guard the first
time yeah so it's very fun watching
someone go oh this looks good
even someone who's like experienced
drinking bubble like knowing that it's
coming there's like a little like oop
because
the thing the thing i don't get about um
what can i call it boba culture because
like i guess there's a [ __ ] culture
around it now wrestling japan yeah
because it's like that
because what i don't get is that people
go out of their way to get boba and i'm
just like it's great why i have never
understood it especially in japan when
like couple of years ago when the burba
craze was huge yeah of just like these
like high school kids lining up for like
two hours oh yeah
like
what's it's literally milk tea like i
get some desserts i get some special ice
creams you know because because there's
there's only like there's ice cream huh
yeah honestly yeah yeah ice cream is a
great dessert i didn't say it wasn't a
great dessert i was defending jelly is
it the best dessert it's the way they
cook the tapioca pearls
the what is it the best dessert it is
the best dessert oh thank you carry on
oh my gosh
that doesn't mean that doesn't that
doesn't mean jelly's a bad dessert
jelly's still good yeah
they're so different though oh the boba
jelly yeah the jelly texture is entirely
different it's way more chewy it is i
love the chewiness of it yeah
do you ever wedge them in between your
teeth i don't really use it that much so
no okay
what
is that part of boba culture but also
yeah what the [ __ ]
you know what is that what you need to
do like assimilate into boba culture no
is that what boba drink is doing
you're just playing with textures with
the food i just i just wanted to know
how is it yeah no because like some some
some cuisines some desserts some snacks
i understand people going out of their
way to get this certain thing boba it's
just milk tea it's it's it's milky with
a bit of jelly in it and i just i just i
just don't in the mouth
with the chewing
you can do that with most foods mainly
is there a food that's like tapioca
that's same cheese jelly mochi no no
jelly is soft mochi there's more bites
do you like mochi actually yeah
i i i i'm i'm like on the fence about
mochi because i like the juice i like
the way it tastes but then i also feel
like it should come with a health
warning because oh my god i like i'm a
normal functioning human being who can
who can who knows how to chew their food
and has no problem doing it and even i
feel like i'm going to [ __ ] choke
another mochi if i chew it wrong a lot
of old people actually die no i i i i
know i like mostly like rip it into bits
and then just eat the bits that you can
like yeah you have to take small bites
out yeah you can't just throw the whole
mochi in your mouth yeah
like [ __ ] mouth breathers should not
eat mochi like it's it's like yo yo
you're not bringing this back
you're playing with fire man
because their nose is congested
no if you're if you if your nose is
congested and you eat mochi that's
that's like that's like instant death
to death right there i'm pretty sure you
can just die anyway god how do mouth
breathers kiss them
they just breathe into each other's
mouth
i don't think about the word i don't
think they are incapable of breathing
through their nose i think it's the
default
who have internet explorers their
default browser it doesn't mean they
can't use chrome it's just that they
don't all the time they're just at a
disadvantage
like it's just slow and you know
consequences happens